what's going on guys this is rob and
let's talk about madame webb
specifically let's talk about what
they're going to do
with madame webb because if i'm being
honest with you guys i think madame web
is going to be the antithesis to know
the simeone god she's going to be a
multiversal character so first things
first right a lot of people are kind of
pissed off because apparently dakota
johnson being cast as madame webb seems
to fly in the face of who they expected
basically like an old blind woman um i
imagine a lot of people probably feel
that way because when they learned that
madame web was going to get a solo film
they googled madame webb saw it was an
old blind woman and then just you know
got mad on twitter because twitter loves
to be angry here's the thing taking that
google search one step further
you actually end up learning there's two
madame webs or there have been two
madame webs so let's talk about the
first one right cassandra webb so
cassandra webb appeared way back in
amazing spider-man number 210 back in
1980 and in reality she was more
interesting in spider-man the animated
series than she's ever been in the
comics but in effect she suffered from a
degenerative muscle disease that
basically made it impossible for her to
be able to move and even really just
survive on her own so her late husband
ended up building a machine that
literally looks like a giant spider's
web that she would just be connected to
she would just sit there and it just
kept her alive but she served as a kind
of cirrus right given her psychic
ability she served as a sort of guide of
sorts to peter parker but was never
really that interesting in the comic
book so i'm being honest with you guys
now take that discussion of cassandra
webb and table it for a second which fyi
will do like an actual madame webb
explained video on comics explained
sometime this week but table that
explanation kind of sit on the back
burner for a second and let's talk about
julia carpenter who's cool i guess so
julia carpenter was originally part of
the secret wars event from back in 1984.
when she first popped up you didn't
really know anything about her you
didn't know how she got there where she
was from and spider-man was like it's
weird that your outfit looks like mine
she's like yeah i'm a spider woman right
but you end up fast forwarding to her
solo series and what you find out is
she's friends with a woman named valerie
cooper now those of you guys who are
familiar with comics you know who
valerie cooper is if you're not valerie
cooper had her hands on a lot of really
shady things when it came to like
mutants and superheroes and things like
that but with regards to this discussion
here she was part of a group called the
commission on superhuman activities so
as an example of some of this stuff that
the commission did uh a lot of you guys
saw falcon in the winter soldier right
and you saw that like john walker had
basically replaced sam wilson as captain
america and that led to everything kind
of popping off even though really sam
wilson was the one that let it happen
because he refused to take up the shield
that's based on the storyline that
initially saw john walker becoming
captain america in marvel comics the way
that worked is the commission actually
fired steve rogers because they argued
that the captain america shield and the
uniform and all that stuff is property
of the federal government so they can
decide who plays the role of captain
america and who doesn't now of course
they basically brought in john walker
guy lost his mind they canned him and
brought steve rogers back right so
that's that's really how that works but
that's the kind of stuff the commission
did one of the other things the
commission wanted to do was basically
create their own superheroes and so what
ended up happening is because valerie
cooper and julia carpenter were friends
in college valerie cooper approached
julia carpenter to ask her if you want
to be part of like a like a kind of
experiment of sorts and julia carpenter
was like yeah sure whatever so they
ended up exposing her to like spider
venom and some weird you know herbs and
stuff they gave her lsd and she ended up
developing like superpowers right now
the big difference between julia
carpenter and spider-man is that julia
carpenter shoots psychic wedding whereas
spider-man uses like physical webbing
just one of the many differences between
those characters if i'm being honest now
having said that the paths of these two
characters cassandra webb and julia
carpenter cross paths during a story
that was known as the grim hunt the grim
hunt was a story that came out in 2010
and was basically a sequel to like
craven's last hunt and basically the
family of craven the hunter wanted to
get rid of spider-man and so they ended
up kidnapping a whole bunch of members
of the spider family which included
madame webb cassandra weth and so during
this whole storyline basically cassandra
webb died but before she did she passed
on her powers to julia carpenter and
julia carpenter became the new madame
webb having said that i mean she's done
some stuff which is cool sort of but not
really but that's how she ended up
becoming madame webb now why does this
matter well to be honest with you guys
first things first i do not want to see
a movie with an old blind woman sitting
in a chair
by herself that movie sounds boring as
hell i guess we could get an actual
origin which would be way beyond what we
got in the comics but here's the thing
julia carpenter makes a lot more sense
for a variety of reasons the first is
because say for example they did go with
cassandra webb they went with an old
blind woman well the most logical choice
for somebody like that would be like
judy dench or somebody like helen mirren
or whatever the problem is longevity you
might get two movies out of her and then
that's it whereas if you hire someone
like dakota johnson to play julia
carpenter you can get a ton of movies
out of her right at least 15 years worth
of movies out of her which kind of seems
to be about the standard right to be
honest 10 to 15 years worth of movies
from various people tom holland is you
know said he's more or less kind of done
playing spider-man i don't really know
how they reconcile that with the ending
of spider-man no way home uh robert
downey jr played iron man for about 10
years or so chris evans played captain
america for about the same amount of
time of course hugh jackman played
wolverine for like 17 years so i would
say on average between 10 to 15 years in
terms of actors playing a particular
role in movie form in the comic book
landscape or at least the comic book
movie landscape so in that way it makes
more sense to hire dakota johnson to
play julia carpenter more so than that
though i think that there's a much
bigger thing going on here than just a
madame webb film if what they wanted to
do was make a movie focused on julia
carpenter portrayed by dakota johnson
basically becoming spider woman they
would have just called it that they
would have been like spider woman
starring julia carpenter played by
dakota johnson coming soon from sony
right i mean they would have just left
it that way but they called it madame
webb what i think they're doing here is
they're building madame webb up into
what will eventually become a kind of
multiversal character right somebody who
has the antithesis to know the symbiote
god now here's the reason why i say that
sonia and marvel have recently said that
they want that they are working on a
series or at least uh maybe a trilogy of
films however many films they end up
making that feature noel the symbiote
god right the guy who created the
symbiotes this makes sense null is a
multiversal character we know that null
is a multiversal character because in
the second venom film when the symbiote
was talking to tom hardy like when they
were teleported into the mcu the venom
symbiote recognized peter parker
spider-man the reason why they're there
is because the venom symbiote knows that
peter parker's spider-man the reason the
venom symbiote knows peter is spider-man
is because topher grace got the venom
symbiote and sam raimi spider-man 3 and
topher grace knew that peter parker was
spider-man the symbiotes share a hive
mind so what one symbiote knows in one
universe the other symbiotes know in
every other universe right we know that
because when the symbiote was talking to
eddie brock it was like you couldn't
possibly comprehend something like 80
billion years across the history of the
multiverse i'm using 80 billion as a
ballpark i don't remember if that was
the exact number basically a huge amount
of time across the entirety of the
multiverse you can possibly comprehend
that much information right so it would
make sense if you look at the entirety
of like the spider-man movies we've been
getting up to this point right remove
the villains remove like michael morbius
and remove like adrian tombs right and
trying to figure out where does michael
morbius take place like i said remove
all of that right just look at the
spider-man movies since really the
introduction of tom holland into the mcu
as spider-man right spider-man
homecoming spider-man far from home and
spider-man no way home it's a
three-movie origin story we didn't know
that until we got to no way home but
it's a three-movie origin story
spider-man into the spider-verse the
origin of miles morales and to a degree
the origins of the other characters who
appeared in there spider-man beyond the
spider-verse the origin of miguel o'hara
spider-man 2099 and whatever other
variations of spider-man will exist in
that particular movie assuming they
choose to give us one what we're getting
here from sony and largely from the
marvel cinematic universe is a building
up of the spider-man characters
spider-man mythos across the entirety of
the multiverse what better way to have
all that build up and lead into a great
big huge kind of event uh than in some
kind of a post-credit scene or some
moment in a movie or something like that
following the madame webb solo film
where basically she brings like tom
holland and miles morales maybe a couple
other together and says like you guys
need to go find the spiderman from
across the multiverse because nola's
coming back and he is a threat unlike
anything you've ever faced before and we
need as many spider-man from across the
multiverse as we can possibly get you
want to add a little icing on the cake
have the forces of null basically play
the role of the inheritors from
spider-verse that the forces of knoll
are traveling across the multiverse
killing spider-man and so madame web's
like we have to do something about this
right we got to bring all these
spider-man together and find a way to
stop null and his forces or whatever it
is it's not that impractical especially
coming out of no way home when you had
andrew garfield toby and tom all
basically hanging out together coming
together right i think that's a taste of
what we're gonna end up seeing that
they're probably gonna end up coming
back as spider-man i wouldn't be
surprised if we got like an amazing
spider-man 3 for like andrew garfield
and they're like yeah man like this
madame webb and everything all ties into
it right i wouldn't be surprised if that
was the case and that was what was
really going on here that madame webb is
less about julia carpenter and us being
introduced to a new spider woman and
more about them building up this just
colossal multiversal threat that is null
the symbiote god but let me know what
you guys think down in the comments
thank you all for watching and uh yeah i
will catch you all later
peace